free state of Jones is directed by Gary
Ross and stars Matthew McConaughey
alright alright alright as a man who's
leading a rebellion against the
Confederate Army he decided that
whatever he is seeing isn't for him and
these things just aren't sitting well
with him he's witnessing farms being
raided peoples live stalks being taken
people's children being sold into
slavery and he decides you know what
it's time to start an army of my own and
he creates the free state of Jones a
small army of people who want things to
be done a little more lawfully this
movie had excellent potential not just
from its great cast but its story this
is a story that at its core could be so
compelling so emotionally resonant so
exciting so dramatically riveting and
moving and it's none of those things as
I drove home from this screening I
thought of the best way that I could
describe this movie to you guys and the
best thing I can say is cinematic nyquil
there's no if ands or buts about it free
state of Jones is an extremely boring
film the compelling story at its core is
reduced to a series of funeral speeches
war speeches other speeches speeches
tons of them after the first funeral
speech delivered by Matthew McConaughey
I thought that was that was good great
performance after the second I thought
hmm all right well that's that's a lot
of speeching after the third this movie
is nothing but fucking speeches if
potential could make a great film then
this is a great film
there is so much they could have done
with this story whenever something
compelling happens or exciting or
intense it's over almost instantaneously
and the film just can't escape feeling
like a History Channel original movie
it's very educational it's very sermon
II there's a lot of preaching going on
and it's unfortunately bogged down by
all of those elements and the best thing
that rises out of that is a great lead
performance by Matthew McConaughey and
in fact a great performance by its
entire cast I'm going to try not to
butcher this but Maher shala Ali is
fantastic in the film as is Gugu
mbatha-raw please forgive me if I read
your
names but you were both uniformly
excellent in this movie as well as Keri
Russell all the performances were very
good it's just that the movie can escape
this incredible feeling of
made-for-television according to IMDB
the budget for this movie was 65 million
dollars leaving the screening I felt
like I had just watched a History
Channel or an A&E original movie and
this is 65 million dollars people and
it's told in such a small confined way
and the only thing that can really rise
above this movie's limitations are the
performances I found free state of Jones
to be a long boring visually murky and
drab film that went on for way too long
with nothing really to offer aside for
some good performances and a strong
opening that divulge a--'s into a series
of sermonizing moments of preaching over
and over again speeches and speeches and
nothing but speeches I'm going to give
free State of Jones a d-plus
easily one of the biggest miss
opportunities of 2016 so far if
potential made a great movie then we
have a great movie because this movie is
brimming with it but none of it is
reaped it's just squandered it's so
disappointing if you couldn't tell I
wouldn't recommend seeing this movie
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes